bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
pour ce championnat du monde d'échecs
2016 entre donc le tenant du titre
magnus carsen pièce blanche face à
sergei k ras yakine pièce noire
les deux joueurs sont donc à égalité
après deux premières parties nulles de
ce match car s'il avait des marges et du
pion dame
dans la première il a de nouveau les
blancs qu'est-ce qui va jouer ce qu'il a
essayé d'insister sur cette ouverture
pour tenter autre chose et ce qui va
varier on va le voir tout de suite avec
son premier coup magnus carsen débute
cette troisième manche par le coût du
roi le coût du coeur du roi donc il va
arrive donc il aime bien il aime bien
tenté un peu des choses très différentes
on le voit il se distingue l'on peut
dire des précédents champions du monde
qui essayait beaucoup plus de forcer
l'entrée et le la canalisation de
l'adversaire sur les des variantes
précisé préparer à une varie beaucoup
et dès le premier coup donc avec le coût
du pion du roi a eu quatre donc carrière
qui ne répond parle 5k relief trois
qu'avait laissé 6 donc on est dans la
même partie inverse à en couleurs
inversées de la précédente car yakine
avec les blancs avaient joué ici le coup
de rue lopez c'est à dire le fou en b 5
que va faire car cette fois que c'est
lui qui a les blancs et bien la même
fougue 5 aussi ici on avait eu par
contre le coût à 6,2 carsen dans la
précédente
la fameuse grandes variantes oui au ps
de l'espagnol est ici et bien car y'a
qui ne répond pas on va le voir tout de
suite cavaliers 6,6 alors c'est pas la
même alors celle là c'est la défense de
berlin on l'appelle en contre attaque
directement le pion sans chercher à
chasser le fou
cette variante a été mis à la mode un
championnat du monde jamais avant elle
avait tu es vraiment un jouet c'était
kramnik dans son match face à kasparov
et qui avait réussi à tenir avec les
pièces noires toutes les attaques de
kasparov sur cette ouverture qui avait
un peu
épuisé un kasparov en défense il avait
réussi à lui empêcher toute toute
initiative dans cette ouverture très
très solide le mur de berlin les blancs
rock et l'a donc qu'elle allait prendre
4 c'est ça c'est la vente principal
c'est que kasparov avait dû jouer c'est
que cramique avait choisi tours 1 on
attaque le cavalier c'est simple les
coûts sont faciles à trouver
en attaque le cavalier on va viser
derrière le pion aux cinq cavaliers des
six a noté qu' on a eu des partis en
tout six entre carsen et anand sur cette
ouverture là si vous regardez le match
car c'est la lande
on a eu aussi une défense de berlin donc
c'est une rue maintenant qui est rentré
dans les moeurs
grâce à accra nick cave l'épreuve cents
alors ça c'est par contre on peut un peu
nouveau puisqu'on peut aussi prendre le
cavalier c6 avec le fou et ensuite
prendre en scène qu'il a il prend tout
de suite en 5 ça c'est peut-être un peu
nouveau comme traitement fawcett est
voilée revient et le feu donc là on
varie des grandes variantes de la berlin
avec cette absence de prise en c6 par le
fou on n'a pas le le doublement des
pions noirs les blancs veulent traiter
la position différemment donc c'est
intéressant la façon de jouer le quart
scène qu'elle allait prendre tout
reprend petit rock
tout ça est normal des quatre à noter
ici que le l'avantagent des blancs quand
même il existe un petit peu c'est que le
cahier des six est mal placé puisqu'il
est devant le pion 17
donc on peut pas jouer des 6 ou des 5 et
le fou c'est 8 aura du mal à sortir de
ce côté là ou alors mission devra jouer
le cavalier mais c'est pas facile de
trouver une bonne case puisque bon tout
de suite en f5 qu'ils aillent à la tour
en c4 ya le fou est un des 5 ou 6 e
cattivi sur gala tour aussi en huit y
seraient et quand même passif donc ils
perdraient beaucoup de temps aux 8,6
pour revenir en limite tf6 ce qui
donnerait beaucoup de temps d'avancé aux
blancs donc fou et 6
on met le fou sur une case active
suffisant le pion des quatre on libère
un petit peu la colo ne peut être il
veut jouer tours 8
à noter comme si on jouait aussi c'est
qu'on va laisser le kabbaliste en
doutant des six donc ce pion va rester
fiche et donc les noirs vont sans doute
jouer b6 pour jouer le fou sur les de ce
côté là et la laque ou très étonnant le
quartier autour d'eux ouais je dois
avouer que je n'ai pas d'explication je
vois pas pourquoi on met à tours 2 c'est
ça me dépasse un peu c'est à dire qu'il
est au sommet comme devant le flou fin
donc on permet aux carriers de bouger à
tours a pas de menace directe ou
indirecte et je ne comprends pas ce coup
vraiment je pense que tout re a l'air
quand même plus direct mais bon donner à
voir un des idées subtil ars coup on
verra ça peut-être une autre fois mais
si ce wiki paraît tout à fait normal
puisque avaya parle toujours pas de
cadre intéressant donc on va jouer soi
fully si ce soit faux bessette soi même
fou à 6 et dans ce cas là la tourbe
domaine encore une fois ce qu'elle fait
là parce que elle va devoir bouger on
prend enfin peut-être que les blancs
vont tenter les noirs d'échangés le fou
de case blanche estime que le fou de
cases noires et est le mieux placé
c'est sans doute ça et tout re 1 donc là
on oublie on voit bien qu'on a joué les
tours en deux temps en un bon tour 8
ça n'a pas l'air quand même être le plus
efficace mais m'en fous et 4 alors là ça
c'est clair puisque on attaque on
attaque on sort le fou mais en même
temps on attaque bien sûr le cahier des
six taureaux menace de [ __ ] en
cavalier avec un doublement des pions
deux pions isolé au centre d'essais des
six
ça sera un gros avantage blanc en termes
de structure les normands pour empêcher
ça avec les coups suivants tu reprends
dame prend ici et noir pourrait
envisager faut prendre des quatre c'est
envisageable dans ce cas là il y aura un
petit problème sans doute puisque après
on peut regarder faut prendre les quatre
ici des galets blancs l'aï six jours et
très certainement fou prend cavaliers
des six
si les noirs maintenant prenez 10 bornes
je peux reprendre mais sa double les
pions et après les blancs même s'ils ont
perdu un pion ses deux pions noirs au
sein de son tellement faible que ils
sont quasiment perdu et que c'est
peut-être un avantage blanc mais il
pourrait se dire mais c'est plus grave
pour les blancs puisque je vais prendre
b2 et dont je venais la tour mais la
regarder une astuce france et 7 et la
dame ne peut pas prendre ici pourquoi il
ya le fameux matt ici du couloir droit
et coincé derrière ses propres pions
donc les noirs seraient obligés de jouer
ici la dame aurait fuite puisque ensuite
ce serait prise aussi pour éviter le mat
dès maintenant peut être que les blancs
pourrait continuer par cahiers des deux
fous prend dans prend tranquillement et
en fait les blancs la fameuse paire de
fou un développement terminé les noirs
peuvent encore jouer des coups comme fou
17 ce genre de choses mais les blancs
sont très très actif par exemple après
fou bessette
on peut jouer car les c4 et bien qu'on a
une qualité en moins c'est pas facile
pour le moment de trouver de quoi jouer
on peut mais là c'est ici food et 6 pour
réattaquer la dame bloquer les pièces
noires la paire de fou doit compenser la
carène la qualité avec un meilleur jeu
de pièces pour les blancs difficile à
estimer mais c'est tout à fait jouable
est tout à fait intéressant et c'est
peut-être sans doute parce que les
primes que larsen donc d'en prendre
après tout reprendre et l'a simplement
donc ici cariat qui ne veut pas rentrer
à ce type de vote
on a une pression souvent tout l'art
akin il est très solide c'est à dire
qu'il évite de rentrer dans les
variantes comme ça peu tendu un peu un
peu déséquilibré il aime bien simplifier
un peu là les causes impressionnant
c'est l'impression qu'ils me donnent un
peu lapidaire l'écho donc dames 7 voilà
donc très solide mais il risque sariska
manqué de l'agressivité
puis c'est rentré assez marrante choisit
pas il peut faire la préparation sans
doute dams est donc la proposent des
changes de dames et donc c'est très
calme
voilà et en même temps on protège le
cavalier donc en cas de prise mission
reprendre la dame
double par les pions donc là car scène
continue son développement
tranquillement leur deal est pas pressé
cali c3 donc toujours pareil il a pas
peur en k2 dames prendre tour croix sur
fou prend des quatre il y aurait fou
prendre cavaliers menace mat du couloir
donc on aurait gagné une pièce donc il
ya rien il n'y a pas de vraie menace
contre le clan des quatre ans donc là
maintenant et noir jouent enfin fou
bessette ils ont fini leur développement
oui on va aider le début que ce fou de
toute façon et se développer par la
cause du cac et des six donc c'est sans
doute tout l'idée des blancs de ce début
c'est de forcer les noirs à rentrer dans
cette structure sur laquelle il estime
qu' il dise ont un meilleur
développement et meilleure coordination
des pièces et ceux qui allaient qui
bloque les pions donc ici regardez
carsen de rentrer dans la finale encore
une finale technique boom dans prend il
vous prend et la a4 donc là taux est
bien placé en a un à quatre petites
attaques de structures encore une fois
on veut on menace à sec
et pourquoi pas ensuite essayé de créer
des menaces qu'ils soient assises par
exemple pour perturber le fouet ouvelle
fou et peut-être ils peuvent pas aller
n'importe où on sait s'il y aura des
saints qu'il ait pris les 6e obligé de
revenir ans et 8
on a l'impression que les noirs sont
glissés donc attention à 4 est ce qu'on
peut permettre à 5 menace qui acquit
derrière menace à 6 ou alors si on joue
à 6 on prend b6 et obtient on est obligé
de partir en un pur isolé en 17 voiliers
avec un petit coup comme ça et tout de
suite on a des soucis donc là le noir
est vite sa part à six voix la voix 6
donc on pourra pas jouer la scène et a6
et sur un cinglant pour huit baies 5 et
c'est terminé
peut-être c'est même le pion blanc qui
peut avoir des soucis sur 1,5 qu'il y
ait un tout petit peu isolé et ça peut
cette fois créé des soucis donc larsen
rentre pas là dedans très simplement
beaucoup et le plan de car celle là
c'est très simple et c'est facile à
jouer pour les noirs c'est plus dur
parce que ses pions sur un peu vis et si
on bouge celui là on laisse le 17 en
arrière et 17 est bloqué par le cavaly
des six qui n'a toujours pas de beaucoup
de vrais case à jouer s'ils bougent le c
7 qui tombe
voilà c'est pas facile volantes mais en
étant précis ça devrait tenir comme
animation g3 et la g5 noir ne laisse pas
le fou justement sur cette diagonale on
voit bien que ça immobilise le cavalier
des six g5 on est protégé par le fou on
pose la question aux fous que tu fais si
tu viens 1,5 je peux jouer sans doute f6
tu es obligé de les changer sinon tu
reviens l'arrière de la scala tu étais
plus aussi actif que sur cette série
gonalon tu fais quand même une pression
indécise sur ces 7 surtout derrière ou
plein car celle des reculs pas parce que
sinon il est très passif il choisit de
donner la paire de fou il faut prendre
les six points et six dans la paire de
fou momentanément puisque fou j'ai deux
ça y est bon on va éliminer le fou de
casse noirs ici de le fou noir de classe
blanche fou bessette
si les noirs essaie d'éviter par ces six
bornes ils ont touché leur fou ce serait
pas bon donc les noirs quand même
échanges
la paire de fou c'est terminé ça a duré
qu'un coup pas de problème donc hollande
dans une finale maintenant c'est ça
qu'il fallait juger cavaliers contrefous
c'est ça qui visitent carsen et il
estime ici que sa position et est quand
même très certainement un peu meilleur
sinon ils seraient pas rentrer là dedans
au moins égal et sans doute un peu
meilleur alors pour quelle raison ça
pourrait être un peu mieux
d'abord ça lui de jouer ah non c'est pas
lui de jouer c'est au noir
c'est sans doute que le nouveau roi ici
peut aller facilement vers le centre le
roi noir un peu plus dur puisque sur
cinq qui aura le pion
au rayon des clients pêche voyait
toujours le plein de c'était un peu
immobilisé est-ce que les pions ici bon
effectivement censure cases noires donc
que c'est une restriction par rapport
aux fous on ya pas mal de pions mais ils
sont tous là il ya peu pâle il ya pas
deux îlots très éloignés l'un de l'autre
est ce que le fou peut profiter de sa de
sa puissance de feu par rapport aux
cavaliers sur cette structure-là bon
voilà c'est des estimations qu'il faut
faire c'est pas facile à un juge et ça
donc ici on regarde carrière kim joo f5
f5
il empêche une centralisation du roi
rapide sans doute ici c'est des rois f3
possible suivi droit j'ai 4 4 il empêche
le roi de d'avancé en jouant f5 y met un
pion sur la couleur opposée du fou et il
libère lacazette pour son roi voilà donc
c'est sans doute un bon coup pour toutes
ces raisons carsen continue ici par un
coup actifs
ils placent au mieux son cavalier c'est
intéressant cavaliers des 5 auquel et 5
c'est bien il est ici sur une case du
fait pression sur ses pions si on joue
c'est si son père b 6
si on joue le fou on perd c'est cette
donc il est très bien placé ici voilà ça
suffit pour justifier ce coup pour f7
pour mémoire et la carlier 3 alors
qu'avec trois peut-être y vise la casse
et 4 qui attaquent le fou menace
pourquoi pas enfin pour menacer de
prendre ici on attaquait f5 mais
replaçons cavaliers ils pouvaient
peut-être pas resté très longtemps des
saints qui aurait eu droit aux six de
toute façon et la noire choisissent
simplement droit f6 il fallait protéger
5 on n'avait pas joué f4 puisque en cas
de f4 on affaiblit ses pions ils sont un
peu avancé et puis on met les pions
soucaze noir il vaut mieux garder les
pions sur la case sur casse blanchissent
compte en tout cas ce mois on optimise
son placement donc je pense que l'idée
ici des blancs si on réfléchit bien
c'est que ce pion des quatre et six
pions là sont une restriction du fou
voilà s'il ya suffisamment nos pions
pour que les pions arrive à contrer le
fou pendant que le cavaly s'occupe des
autres classes
c'est peut-être ça que les blancs ont
jugé en termes de structure elle qui
justifie le fait entrer en finale car
les c4 maintenant menaces comme les
prend avec un doublement de pions et
n'avantagent blanc durable donc les
noirs bien sûr évite tout simplement
faire parfois fuite
la position très certainement égal mais
il faut faire jouer précis et ne pas se
faire avoir
ceci dit c'est tout à fait le style de
carsen aussi ici dans ce type de partie
il n'a pas cherché pas forcément à
sortir de l'ouverture avec un avantage
comme un kasparov fischer qui cherchait
à puncher dès le début l'idée c'est que
8 mai sur son avantage il crache pas
dessus c'est pas l'idée mais ils sont
prêts à rentrer dans les finales comme
ça de ce type là un peu atypique
difficile à juger rentre pas dans les
canons habituels mais où il ya encore
pas mal de jeu il faut jouer beaucoup de
choses un peu technique faire des
calculs positionnelle tout autant que
tactique qui sont des vrais partis en
par elle-même en fait voilà c'est ça
c'est à dire qu'il a il dit voilà mais
ce type de vision il faut les traiter il
faut savoir les traiter à toi de me
démontrer que tu sais quand même jouer
aux échecs même dans une position où
apparemment il ya pas grand chose moi je
pense qu'il ya encore pas mal de trucs à
faire il va le démontrer dans cette
partie ça qui est pas mal c'est c'est
qu'il le dit il propose dans son jeu et
en plus bien sûr il ya des montres par
la suite on va voir que ira trouver des
trucs intéressants tour ou un maintenant
les blancs ont fini leurs manoeuvres
d'optimisation regardé comme lecavalier
6 3 a réussi à aller sur la case c4 pas
facile dé 5,3 ces quatre voilà ils
contrôlent les cases noires donc ce fou
et restreint ya parmi eux des coudes
endroit où il peut attaquer le camp noir
le camp blanc ou c'est qu'ils attaquent
il peut pas regarder n'y a pas de
faiblesse
il n'y a pas de pions y aurait le pion
b2 attaquer mais comment il est
impossible il faudrait aller sur cette
grande diagonale c'est c'est même pas la
peine d'y penser
royer
il ya bien deux des quatre au milieu on
pourra jouer ses trois en plus on
resterait le fou en fait on joue avec
les pieds contre le fu un petit avantage
de l'espace d'une pièce vis-à-vis de
l'autre le cavalier lui beaucoup plus
libre en allait attaquer des trucs on
peut venir cinq attaques et 17 si le
pion de cette bouge en à la casse et 6
pour bouger voilà on les blancs sont
plus libres les noirs autour des 8
regardez d'ailleurs on protège le 17 mai
c'est un peu une menace est là tout de
suite quelque 17 gagne en temps il faut
les défendre ensuite on défend de tout
de suite car les kin il défend tout de
suite dé cette menace car les dessins
qui peut envisager de jouer notre combat
est là encore un coup surprenante car
celle là après le tour de début la yul
amène en f4 alors f4 cc c'est presque
c'est presque contre-intuitif un je vous
dirai pas ce que l'on met un pion sur
case noire il était déjà mis là ils
étaient bien protégés
mais après pions prend 1,4 kg gic qui on
prend un f4 on a isolé le pion les
puristes 5 et isolé aussi bien sûr mais
l'huile et la couleur opposée du fou ce
pion et sur la couleur du fou mais en
fait l'idée c'est simplement qu'on veut
venir en f3 et c'est pas facile même si
le foot à ta question
il faudrait que la tour viennent aider à
l'attaqué et c'est quasiment impossible
en fait donc ce pion continue à jouer
contre le foie diverses
voilà on continue à dire finalement je
n'ai pu emmener sur sur les couleurs de
ton coup même si gisèle un pion que tu
peux attaquer en me demandant de le
défendre mais j'ai des bonnes façons de
défense en gagnant de l'espace en juin 3
je me rapproche du centre et ce pion
finalement métropole empêche sur un e 5
empêche son gsm que tu y mets ton fou
donc ils empêchent aussi ce fou de jouer
sur cette diagonale il peut pas rentrer
dans le camp blanc donc je resterai un
temps fou en fait avec médium il y en a
suffisamment pour que suffisamment de
pions que je puisse les mettre sur la
couleur de ton fou qui en fait tu joues
contre toi c'est pas d'essai pas des
cibles mais c'est au contraire d
étouffer des empêcheurs de tourner en
rond b 5
encore un pion sur case blanche on
attaque le cavalier est donc à prendre
des cinq premiers sets il faut bouger le
cavalier
et donc la carcel choisi gagne 3 voilà
c'est les blancs qui attaquent la
faiblesse f5 imaginer que la tour
arrivant que j'ai 5 c'est fini ceux qui
ont perdu ou là donc là un premier
siècle après les cinq cavaliers trois là
et on vise aussi la casse des cinq avec
un échec quitté chèque qui gagne c'est
cette île c'est quand même faire
attention ça donc les noirs jouent le
évident maintenant c'est 6 voilà carrier
qui ajouterait à la russe
c'est normal c'est en russe donc très
très classique tous les pions sans sur
blanc le foot aux cases noires mais mais
mais malgré ça on voit bien qu'il n'y a
pas de cible dans le camp blanc c'est
assez standard pour l'attack mais rien
attaque et que c'est là que car cette
dit il suffit pas de jouer des grandes
idées il faut aussi que ça s'adapte à la
position donc les blogs continue de
placer leurs pièces 33.8 on active la
tour maintenant karekin très bon coup un
tour à 8b sûr on veut venir en a deux
c'est clair en at il la tour c'est très
bon on peut pas dire non plus que les
noirs en avantage en des avantages
décisifs ici il on le fout un peu
restreint bon mais sans plus quoi c'est
à tout moment ça peut s'éclaircir et ils
ont eux mêmes ils sont pas un vrai
danger c'est facile de contrer un tour
g5 ici parce que bien sûr on peut jouer
à 6 de même envisager pourquoi pas
infosys même si c'est dans la vie est
quand même peu moins bien puisque la
tour pour rational g33 poser des
problèmes merci sont vos pas trop
comment on protège mais comment on
progresse mais bien si on joue ce genre
de choses on voit bien que le cavalier
bougeard h 4 par exemple qu alger 2
pièces 4 avec une tour sur le clonage et
il y aura un échec possible dès qu'on
bouge un pion on affaiblit des cases
attention très technique c'est humain
donc tout rejet en quart cette logique
menace et toucher 5
je prends à f5 avec échec ou voire du
cavalier et sur h 6 j'ai peut-être une
on peut le regarder
peut-être sur 1,6 ici on peut vouloir on
peut jouer soit cavale et j'ai deux à
quatre comme peu l'ont attention parce
que le tour va pénétrer aussi peut-être
on laisse aussi le cavalier là pour
protéger ces deux on peut lâcher ce pion
puisqu'on va jouer oui peut-être h là
tout simplement
ça peut-être encore c'est beaucoup plus
direct on laisse le cavalier en défense
sur ces 2 c'est très bon et ici que font
les noirs parce que si les noirs jouer
le tour à deux on pourrait aussi même
jour deux tours à quatre prêtres qui est
légal mais admettons retour à 2 à l'air
très bien
on peut simplement jouer b3 ou on peut
envisager à celle qu aussi bien
peut-être on peut quand même aussi un
visage scène mais b3 et encore mieux
c'est beaucoup plus clair je pense mais
trois oui ça va être bon et là bas il ya
comme une menace et tours j'ai six après
h5 on va jouer cinq ans huit tours j'ai
six échecs lors on est obligé de partir
et le pion ipsen va tomber voyez donc là
c'est sarah leader donc là les noirs
contre attaque tout de suite tout radio
donc b3 logique tout à fait normal tout
est bien vrai un escalier attaque
ces trois équipes magnifique île super
bien placé notez bien cette structure
c'est quand même moi je trouve c'est
très joli
c'est très beau on attaque f5 donc on
menace des tours j'ai sinclair il est en
même temps il défend et en plus quand on
a les pions des 4 et f4 le fou ne peut
pas venir attaquer ce cavalier ce serait
idéal parce que si on pouvait faire
sauter ce défenseur l'avantagent blanc
il disparaît complet c'est presque la
tour noire qui est plus actif que la clé
mais le fait qu'on ait mis les pions
sont quasiment bizarrement et regarder
en plus comme le noir le roi noir sur
cases noires ici sur f6 empêche fou g7
qui attaquerait le pion aussi dans des
cons pour elle pouvait attaquer ces
choses là ça oblige les blancs à bouger
et ça crée des faiblesses mais non tout
est solide et c'est les blancs qui sont
actifs et moi qui veut pas dire que
l'alliance était juste c'est juste que
c'est eux qui guident un peu le jeu pour
l'instant et la c5 ou contre-intuitif là
aussi un petit peu de quarts yakine ont
même bien sûr casino on veut changer
mais en fait l'idée voilà c'est ce que
je disais c'est que ses pions empêche de
ce fou de venir attaquer de cavaliers
ont rejoint ces cinq ans proposant un
échange fo prend j'attaque le défenseur
et c'est tout de suite moi qui prend
l'avantagé évidemment c'est pas l'idée
des blancs ici
de prendre il aurait pu envisager des
cinq missiles ou des saints qui libère
quand même du potentiel pour le fou
parce que ceux qui on va pouvoir venir
en c4 pourquoi parce qu'après pions
prend puis on prend on peut pas enfin on
peut reprendre mais il ya ces deux qui
tombe avec h de derrière à noter aussi
que plus les pions diminue à la fin par
exemple touré cavalli contre thau et
droit c'est nul il faut le savoir donc
bon alors du coup évidemment plus les
pions s'échange qui on se rapproche de
la nulle faut aussi tenir compte de ça
quand on rentre dans le rang derrière
donc la tour g8 de carson ou actifs ou
dynamique je remplace une menace par une
autre donc il veut il a trouvé ça pour
rester actif et ne pas prendre en c5 ou
ne pas jouer des scènes non plus vives
jouer ni l'un ni l'autre
donc ici rouaroua f7 est maintenant
touché de l'idée c'est que bien sûr on a
forcé le roi noir à revenir parce que le
foot sur samir cazin suit donc le
purifient sign on ait pu donner plus
n'est plus défendu donc en cas de prise
en d4 la tour j'ai deux protège ses deux
donc le cavalier peut vous jouer peut
jouer en prenant f5
mais c'est pas grave car elle qui ne
rendent quand même là dedans il veut
donner de l'air à son fou c'est toute
l'idée de cette variante voilà il en
éliminant le club des quatre
il a fait sauter un verrou qui empêche
son fou de jouer melanson fou à pouvoir
quoi qu'il se passe mais là on va
pouvoir sortir sur sur ces cinq sur des
six peut-être voilà sur sur des cases ou
mais surtout sur ses cinq où il va
pouvoir un peu joué contre le cavalier
et aider sa tour un petit peu à créer
des contre je dû au fait qu à deux coups
de la contre activité je dirais plus de
façon à ce que ce soit pas les blancs
qui soit tout le temps en train de
guider de guider le jeu donc là car
scène prend f5 qui ont doublé
mais regardez l'ours est très jolie
karine ici alors si cariat qui n'avait
joué fous ces cinq ça pose problème ici
tout de suite parce que là tout revient
à angers 7 avec essec ou alors on peut
même jouer autre chose ce n'était pas le
meilleur court on va regarder
c'est peut-être quand même bon et donc
peut-être simplement heureux car être
encore plus fort ici qu'à tout
simplement je menace des quatre bien sûr
avec lecavalier le ce2 toujours défendu
mes jeux mena sans doute plus fort
d'aller jouer tour j'ai cet échec groix
bouge et je prends ou alors encore plus
fort peut-être encore s'est joué trois
des cinq attaques le fou j'avance avec
le roi dans une position d'attaquant
et selon wolf où je peux même jouer
décalé des six échecs qui peut prendre
des quatre jeux peut venir qu'à les six
échecs je peux je peux faire énormément
de choses je peux même jouer autour
d'eux si le fou est parti en v6 soit
sept tours 2 pour venir à cet échec
bref je suis énormément de choses
possibles et les noirs ont des problèmes
donc c'est une possibilité
on peut aussi prendre on peut jouer à
détroit en plein de choses en tout cas
on voit bien que le roi ici est
centralisé a donc appris cavaliers
problème 5/4 yakine autant de pas dans
ce piège là ils activent au maximum ses
pièces par le très joli détroit voilà il
sait que ce pion à son futur 24
les bleus prennent quand ils veulent des
trois c'est très très bon coup l'idée
c'est perdu pour perdu il faut jouer t3
très bonne idée puisque ça oblige les
blancs à séparer leurs pions donc les
biens brel et regarder les structures de
pury similaire ici
1 2 3 2 3 voilà elle rien il ya de plus
en plus ici mais c'est au noir de jouer
et simplement tour à 1 et l'idée c'est
que justement comme on a cassé ses pions
ça va être facile de les harceler
on peut jouer tour b1 pour attaquer des
trois c'est pas facile à défendre
on peut tenter tour des 1 on peut tenter
tout referee chèque et c'est très
difficile pour les blondes d'essayer de
protéger tout ça les blancs jouent car
les d4 ils ont gagné un pion grâce à
leur activité et maintenant une
recentralise leurs cavaliers en d4 ils
attaquent bessengue ils veulent pousser
les noirs peut être à jouer b 4 mètres
le pion sur sur cases noires
qui va donc bloqué un peu leur fou fou
prend pas le mien de venir en mai 4 il
centralise le cavalier aussi lequel est
un des quatre et sont bien sûr au centre
et donc les très actifs avec 5 il était
bien aussi mais il était un peu dominé
par le fou puisque le fou contrôler ces
cases
voilà donc il est bien placé b4 donc
voilà c'est quasiment obligée ici
maintenant tour g5 donc les blancs ont
réussi à gagner un pion par ces
manoeuvres on l'a vu par l'activité et
les noirs maintenant par contre ont
suffisamment de jeu sans doute pour
contrer ça à cause du fait qu'ils ont un
joué un bon coup des trois en éclatant
les pulls les pions ici et pour donner
enfin du jeu à leurs fous sachant que
dans ces petits de position donc
maintenant on a bien epyon des deux
côtés de l'échiquier et le fou grâce à
son activité à grande portée
donc le cavaly c'est plus dur mais il y
en a entre l'as donc ils contribuent à
placer aussi et bien le fou qu'on pense
qu'on pense un petit peu l'activité du
calme
donc malgré ce pion - on peut pas dire
vraiment que les blancs ont une avantage
décisif mais bon c'est bien sûr un
avantage toujours il on aura noté aussi
qu'ils ont droit centralisée c'est quand
même pas mal renvoyé comme carcelle a
réussi avec pas grand chose à trouver de
quoi
de quoi gagner quelque chose dans cette
partie en haute estime et nancy claude
roets 37 on peut envisager pourquoi pas
des fous j'ai cette attaque le cavalier
et bien sûr le pion b3 sera pas défendue
donc l'idée du cou noir suivant tourbe
est un très bon et peut-être même les
noirs veulent le mettre en b2 qui oblige
les blancs a essayé de protéger à la
fois 2 est à la fois b3 alors les pompes
pousser les pions monsieur toure fcn de
kars elle pose la question roi où tu vas
ainsi pas facile soit à droite ou à
gauche mais il faut prendre une décision
donc la carabine bien sûr préfère rester
vers le centre roi 8 un petit oeil sur
pas très inquiet sur h7 il pourrait être
un peu inquiet mais surtout rage 5
qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer on peut
regarder un petit peu par exemple en
attaque le pion mais sur ici simplement
h6 voilà
6 et là tout renfort qu'elle bouge parce
qu'elle est mal placé maintenant est ce
que le pion l'empêcher de venir manger
simplicité quand ya pas de pain doré
problème croît 8 ici tour b5 et blanc
maintenant sont très actifs
la tour est active le cai et au centre
le roi est bien placé derrière son pion
pas cf
ils peuvent venir au centre al avantage
de commence être là il est bien là mais
il n'est pas pas décisif les noirs sont
actifs et à tout moment
ce fou peut venir poser des problèmes
terribles au blanc qui pour l'instant
tienne tiennent bien mais c'est ici si
tu es trop de choses qui se découvre ça
reste retourner contre faut faire
attention tout récent échec
l'appareil ou valleroy être choisi si tu
t'éloignes 17 pions age 2 1 qui va voir
qui va être faible et si tu restes
virage 2 6 le pion de détroit donc non
il faut rester bien sûr au centre
voilà roi centralisée cavale et
centralisé mais bien sûr pions faible
h2o est faible et en plus on peut
harceler un petit peu le roi échec
j'invite le roi blanc comme ça à venir
dans le camp noir mais l'idée c'est
qu'on s'éloigne de détroit donc tour d
un voilà donc on voit que l'activité de
la tour compense le pseudo pu tourner au
moins ici c'est clair détroit est
attaquée comment je peux faire il ya qu
un seul coup on comprend assez vite
c'est de venir tôt ou tard en quatre
épreuves pour défendre à la fois des 3h
deux tours revenait sur la colonne âge
et détroit alors que le cavalier des
quatre peut être attaqué ensuite parce
ou g7
on voit bien que ça peut pas tenir voilà
c'est intuitif on n'a pas besoin de
faire beaucoup de variantes pour
comprendre que ce coût des trois était
très bien joué par cars yakine en
éclatant les pions on peut pas tous les
délais défendre ça qui rend la chose
très difficile et donc l'activité n'est
que illusoire en fait est le pion de
plus c'est illusoire
donc tu aurais cinq échecs de carson qui
tente qui pousse les noirs à la faute
ils essaient de le vian des huit
peut-être aller vers 20 d'éviter loigne
toi un petit peu des pions du plomb et
c'est tout laisse-moi avancé remémorant
f6 henri vii
ensuite je vais pousser mon pions passé
non non on rêve cette bien sûr on
réussissait pas de problème tour des
cinq attaques le pion normal mais on
propose un échange des trois déjà contre
17 moyens de plus en plus les noirs se
rapproche de la nul ton pas trop inquiet
je pensais voir ici mais il faut faire
attention pour prendre des trois donc on
est cet échec
attention quand même ici peut y avoir
quand même des thèmes aussi le roi blanc
est très avancé et bien sûr si le la le
renoir va être obligé d'aller sur la
huitième il en va le faire tout de suite
par huit
donc il peut y avoir des thèmes de maths
faut faire attention à ça est ce que par
exemple ici les noirs pouvaient aller
sur g8
sans doute mais ça aurait été sans doute
très dangereux faut faire très attention
par exemple 3 e 4 regardez juste pour
vous montrer qu'il ya des problèmes
la tour vient en d1 tout simplement est
maintenant un coup simple comme tours b
7 commence à faire la pression ici sur
le sur le pionnier sur le cube et 4 et
c'est pas facile ici pour les pour les
noirs de trouver de trouver du jeu mais
sur le fou protège ici mais mon projet
local et ses 6
on va pouvoir aussi jouer cavalier e 6
qui attaquent le faut et fuite qui
menacent tour v8 avec le clouage du fou
et pour défendre pour défendre tout ça
avec le roi sur le huitième c'est pas
simple et il est éloigné donc les noirs
préfère aller à huit attaquants la tour
on gagne un temps et on est moins en
forme et que 2 que du côté de l'est loin
le plus rage sept cette emprise mais
aussi le cavalier donc on peut pas on
est obligé avec la tour ici de de
revenir sur la de revenir sur la soie
cette colonne
donc ici tour des 5
edouard joue tour h3 voilà on continuent
d'harceler et voyez bien que ce pion
peux pas le défendre
donc ça il est allé noir vont récupérer
voyez que l'inquiétude est passé c on
voyais bien que ces purs éclaté grâce à
ce superbe coup des trois qui active le
fou ne permettent pas aux blancs
d'envisager une position qui a la foi
permet de tenir les pions et en même
temps de progresser on était obligé de
choisir il vous faisait progresser ce
qui est bien bien sûr ils sont quand
même menaçant sas et menaçant le roi est
bien placé ce qu'ils ont en effet quand
même passé au milieu on y en a un ça va
peut-être pouvoir jouer un rôle aussi
est il vraiment assure la huitième voilà
quand même et en échec toujours des
petits coups pouces et d'essayer de
pousser l'adversaire à la faute
roy f7 et noir restent à proximité de ce
pion qui est le pion potentiellement un
peu faible si on met aussi un vis-à-vis
rouaroua ça permet d'envisager tour
échec et le roi enfin samba on est un
peu moins sous pression des pièces
blanches
voilà ensuite ce coup tours et saint
croix f7 et noir voilà vont pouvoir
repousser un peu le roi blanc et prendre
le pion ensuite tours 2 les noix les
blancs par cette manoeuvre reviennent à
eux deux pour protéger le pion mais on
voit bien qu'on ne peut pas tout tenir
encore une fois regardez ici d'ailleurs
h3 la torah ta cage de mais aussi b3 et
ce cavalier bien regarder c'est ce qu'on
avait dit tout à l'heure où g7
et oui ça y est le défenseur du cube et
3 est attaqué par le fou on peut pas
voilà on peut pas tout tenir on est
obligé de faire mes choix bon il ya des
malheurs vous faire attention maintenant
cavale et 6,6
attention munitions jeu contre attaque
sur b4 mais aussi attention attention il
peut y avoir des tours cet échec
attention contre des menaces aussi
peut-être potentiellement plus
dangereuse il faut faire attention
imaginons que les noms et les les noirs
ici prennent le pion eb tron pour voir
ce qui se passe
regardez dans ce cas là on peut jouer
pour eux cet échec qui semble dangereux
aussi mais aussi il ya aussi encore un
autre coup qui est cavalier des huit
échecs on regarde ce qui se passe
j'imite quasiment forcé on pourrait
venir ensuite aussi on va regarder
d'abord j'imite g8
alors les ici parce qu'il ya le
vis-à-vis au revoir et c'est maintenant
tour 8 c'est presque maths parce que
lacazette cette île prise par le
cavalier c'est presque un mode du
couloir ya plus qu il n'y a que fou et
fuite à jouer ici et là simplement
bonjour et très certainement roi m6
l'idée c'est d'empêcher roi f7 et là
maintenant comment parler car elle est
aussi ce qu'ils gagnent le fou et c'est
en plus c'est presque là tu sais un
quasi match
il ya sans doute un match où on va être
obligé tout donné quoi là et je vois pas
trop à quoi joue étroite rocco jouer ici
pardon imaginons qu'on joue un coup pour
le tour h3 par exemple ici pas facile de
trouver des coûts maintenant je joue
simplement attention oui il ya un
cavalier il ya un tour h6 échec ici on
peut jouer 25 simplement gagnant on
avance le pion passé ici tour h3c pour
venir en 1 h 6 échecs
le roi est obligé de partir par exemple
en scène il ya toujours la menace qu
avait lieu le 6 e si je suis protégé par
le roi le pion je pourrais prendre très
certainement et en plus j'aime pion qui
est proche de dames faut faire attention
à ça quand même faut faire des calculs
mais ça doit ça doit tenir par exemple
si les noirs jouent ici un coup comme
allez on va dire tour h5 pour empêcher
même f6 qui est peut-être aussi encore
une menace
on joue simplement cac valeo 6 menace
tour en maths tranquillement les blancs
là ici un avantage net voilà attention
attention ici la menace peut être qu'à
bâle et des huit communes viennent le
voir c'est dangereux
oui on avait vu dit j'avais dis quand
même que je voulais voir sur cavaler d83
j'imite non on voulait voir ici voilà
royal 8
royer fuite possible aussi dans ce cas
là on pourrait jouer avec les blancs
regarder cabello six échecs
le roi est obligé de venir par exemple
en f7 ou au g8
imaginons qu'il vienne en g8 parce que
la tour j'ai deux on voit bien qu'ils
aient un clouage et c'est gagné et
suroît f7 on peut jouer qu'à bâle et j5
voilà l'idée c'est que maintenant
cavalier protège la case of 7
donc si on vient sur la huitième on est
on est en quasi couloir sur g8 toujours
pareil aux échecs suite eu lieu six et
si on vient en effet 8 est bien seul
pion h7 qui tombe tout simplement
et là en plus la table continue voyez
que les noirs sont quand même vous voyez
dans un quasi corner coin latour
l'empêchent d'aller sur la colonne e
leroy le domine et le cavalier manoeuvre
sans que le foot puisse faire grand
chose à part être là quand un gros pions
un petit peu en défense mais pas très
capable de défendre grand chose donc il
faut faire attention en un sens on peut
se défendre mais il faut pas faire
n'importe quoi
bien entendu ici fallait pas prendre le
coup mais trois quarts aile qu'ils
tombent pas dans le piège
mais il fit donc c'était intéressant de
voir ça pour comprendre ce cook avait
laissé six qui est en fait un coup qui
empêche les noirs de reprendre b3 tout
de suite mais la manoeuvre des noirs de
harcèlement continu et c'est très fine
et noir les pour les blancs de tenir la
position voilà torres cing le roi blanc
va quitter sa position menaçante est
obligé de revenir angers 4 voilà
et maintenant on continue pour ces cinq
ici voilà le cavalier maintenant est
attaqué comme le roi n'est plus en
mesure d'aider calais des huit tout ça
il ya plus de vraies menaces - on est
tranquille ou pas de gros gros soucis
car scène continue comme sony des câbles
et des huit échecs mais maintenant
regardez simplement roi g6 et oui c'est
pas la même on va pas sur la huitième
pour se faire clouer le kung fu par tour
8.8 faux et fuite avec des petits sans
doute des petits soucis
non non on profite notre manoeuvres
autour de cette question pour venir en
chai 6 on est on est bien placé 46 alors
quasi fourchette
attention le fou est protégé donc c'est
pas une vraie fourchette mais on attaque
de pièces et là les noirs ne se trompe
pas il pourrait jouer tour b 3 mais ça
pourrait poser des soucis de tourbe et 3
parce que sur tomber trois regarder qui
attaquent le pion les blancs peuvent
progresser f5 échec ou voit le roi et en
plus je peux prendre une vue le cavalier
avec un pion qui presque adam là qui
avance très vite en rock est pas loin
une tour il peut y avoir très vite des
menaces coupe les deux dames et de maths
attention au final de tout aussi bien
parce que c'est souvent on croit qu'on a
l'avantagé puis à la fête c'est nul et
voilà c'est on voit bien que c'est très
dangereux et 5h tiendra donc qu'ils se
trompent pas car iachini si il joue
d'abord il a promis profite du fait que
le roi et angers 6 pour jouer à 5
voilà très vite très joli coup h5 j'en
profite pour encore une fois éloigné le
roi de la manoeuvre
donc on est obligé de repartir est-ce
qu'on peut venir h4 sans doute pas
puisque vous et si ces chèques ne
fouille pas plus mal passé en revue six
comme gsm et le roi est encore obligé de
partir encore plus loin on repousse le
roi tranquillement et donc c'est ce qui
se passe pour un f3 maintenant carrière
qui ne perd pas de temps il peut jouer
tour ces trois échecs et on attaque à la
fois le roi est froid et le pion b3 roi
4 hélas les noirs choisit bien entendu
gardé leur fou qui est potentiellement
plus forts que lecavalier or les
manoeuvres qu'on a vu de d'attac de
maths qui peuvent avoir lieu mais là
c'est fini une fois qu'on a repoussés le
roi c'est la plus et menacent donc
simplement que je vous fous et 6 il dit
bon écoute là tu as un problème voilà tu
as une pure attaque et tu fais quoi à
noter qu'en réussissent ici donc je
continue contre la casse des quatre on
peut pas venir protéger ni l'un ni là et
avec la tour si on met en b2 basse est
très très faible on est en plus en
attaque transparente par le fou jouer
simplement un coup comme tours sans
doute pour ces 6 et déjà on a des gros
problèmes
et s'il reste tour 3 c'est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs carsen tension tour trois
faux pas échangé des tours si on échange
le tour là le pion de plus avec cavalli
contrefout ces gagnants il n'y a pas de
pions faible maintenant puisque les
pions sont sont le cube et 3 n est pas
sur la case du fou le clanche de est
inattaquable il peut venir en jeu 3
quand il veut on un pion pas c'est net
c'est sans doute gagnant cette phase est
gagnant c'est sûr c'est une pas sans
doute donc on est chanceux surtout pas
les tours c'est ça qui nous permet de
tenir la position mais on joue le très
joli h4 pas mal h4 pas mal mais n'ont
pas peur là d'un échange de tours alors
qu'est-ce qui se passerait surtout
reprendre tour ici pour regarder
baignoire simple look sans doute bien
sûr prennent du plomb on aime bien passé
alors quand il ya des pions passé qui
ont éloigné comme ça avec des pions
passé le fou est sans doute toujours
supérieurs aux cavaliers pas ce qui est
encore une fois il peut à la fois
défendre d'un côté attaque et de l'autre
alors que le cavalier pouvoir aller d'un
côté alors qu'il faut qu'ils fassent des
bons là à l'idf alors faire quelque
chose contre l'avancée du plan de masse
tarifaire dame dont vous jouez un coup
comme on peut peut-être joué f5 d'abord
mais c'est dangereux
le rush 5 leroy ensuite va venir angers
4 problème c'est ça c'est qu'il va
falloir bouger le roi et des clora bouge
par exemple ici et noir vont prendre
l'aventage avec rolf cinq attaques
lecavalier on va enfin prendre le pion
et on a le fou contre le cavalier dans
une finale avait dit pionner de côté
peut-être un léger avantage sans doute
nulle parce qu'il ya pas assez de pions
le câble et va se sacrifier au pire
contre le club qui reste et c'est
terminé
donc ici les noirs donc enfin ici
surtout 3 les blues jouent h3 voilà h3
affaire l'élu h 4 h quatre ans là on
avait dit on avance du côté de l'ex-roi
h trois ans mais le pion bien entendu
sur la case opposé du fou là c'est
classique comme coup le fou du coup et
passifs puisqu'il protège uniquement h4
et attaque la b3 il protège aussi
potentiellement des quatre quand il veut
mais il n'est pas attaquant c'est un fou
passifs s'en [ __ ] défense
torcéen maintenant des mois ont toujours
un peu moins est-ce que c'est suffisant
sans doute pas ici cavaliers fuite échec
continue à faire des manoeuvres
est ce que tu vas te tromper bref cette
cavale et 17 attaques le fou la finale
deux tours et sans doute avantageuse
pour les blancs est ce que ces gagnants
je ne sais pas c'est très difficile a
jugé toujours les finales de tours mais
peut-être peut-être en tout cas faut le
calcul et c'est ça le problème faire
même si gagnant quand on sait pas si
c'est gagnons pas les noirs sont obligés
d'estimé est-ce que la finale mais il le
sait car la guinée connaît par coeur et
finale deux tours lycée peu c'est déjà
sans doute difficile mais regardez moi
aussi donc ça veut dire qu'il a estimé
que la finale deux tours bielle malgré
le calme - et sans doute nulle alors que
voyez si on n'est pas champions du monde
ou si on n'est pas ce niveau là on sait
pas c'est difficile à juger un champ de
plus quand même finale deux tours alors
qu'il reste d'autres pions parce que
s'il y avait que le pion on sait qu'avec
la position de philidor la fameuse quand
le roi noir et devant le pion je vous
renvoie bien entendu à l'analyse de
philidor son magnifique livre 1777 viiie
siècle où déjà il avait démontré comment
annuler les finales deux tours avec
maintien de plus mais là il ya encore
des pions ce qui fait que on peut se
retrouver
tôt ou tard avec non pas un seul qui ont
passé mais deux donc là ça complique
l'estimation mais là bon d'après carrick
insee nul sinon il n'aurait pas laissé
le fou en prison par déduction ça arrive
à le savoir
donc ici calais b 6/4 scène bell lui
aussi c'est que les noirs peuvent s'en
sortir ne prend pas le fou il rentre pas
dans la finale il veut continuer à jouer
pour le gain tour des uns et la f5 échec
thank échec m'attaque le roy on met le
pion en maintenant cette fois sur la
couleur opposée du fou mais voyez tout
de suite en faisant ça le roi déjà peu
plus à l'est sur la casim 5 voilà on
avance le pion certes mais on s'enlève
une possibilité pour le roi d'avancé
mais qu'on ne pouvait pas prouver
c'est là pour et par chasser le roi noir
de cette 6ème ranger qui nous empêchent
d'avancer faut bien trouver quelque
chose possible progresser donc il le
fait avec le pion mais c'est difficile
maintenant regarder leur one leblanc
pour aller on sait que c'est impossible
et pour fc séville alpine donc on est un
peu coincés on s'auto ques en quelque
sorte mais on a repoussé le roi noir
maintenant cavaler ces quatre là on
essaye avec le cavalier de se replacer
peut-être qu'avec des six camps le tour
à bouger peut être un cavalier cinq plus
tard on essaye de repousser le roi noir
et d'essayer de progresser un peu pas
facile pour des quatre échecs
le roi est obligé de reculer voilà on
voit bien que c'est très difficile
d'avancer c'est sans doute déjà nul
malgré tout malgré le pion l'a toujours
pareil l'activité très difficile de tout
défendre à la fois et de progresser en
même temps fou g5 bien joué où va la
tour si tu quittes la troisième et à
tour échec et b3 peut tomber
et si si tu quittes pas la troisième on
va pas où tu vas parce que déçu parce
qu'il part en d3 - c3 s'est perdu donc
très joli coup infligé cinq tranquille
tours 4 voilà ça y est c'est l'heure un
tour des trois échecs
moi j'ai quatre attaques le fou
attention donc faut encore faire un tour
j'ai trois échecs au h5 ne peut pas
prendre ni h3 ni b3 puisqu'une foot
attaquer mais c'est pas grave ils seront
prises il suffit d'enlever le fou et on
va pas comment on va défendre les deux
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs fawcett a
hélas bon pour jouer tour trois
peut-être deux ou trois pour protéger
les deux mais dans ce cas l'attention de
vos trois tours est touchée cinq échecs
roi apprend et on prend 1,5
on a éliminé un pion et ses problèmes
faut pas oublier que quand il reste une
pièce suffit sacrifie la pièce contre le
dernier pion et que ce soit nul donc il
suffit pas de croire que l'on a gagné la
pièce ici ça suffit 1
il faut encore un pion pour gagner comme
plus donc ici cavaliers ces clichés pour
qu'arsène continuent à harceler le le
roi blanc replacer son cavalier essayer
de gagner de la place et ni de l'espace
6 il a calé jkd sans doute très bon coup
pourquoi il fait ça le cavalier donc
bloquent l'action de la tour il y aura
pas tout j'ai cinq échecs bloc et en
même temps on peut pas prendre les sûr
avec f5 sinon père le fou et bien que
les deux pions soit en prison faire
est-ce qu'on peut récupérer sans doute
parce que on peut regarder quand même
est-ce que les douars pourrait sacrifier
tout ça pour prendre les deux pions
parce qu'à la tour et cavaliers contre
roy c'est nul il faut savoir donc ici
par exemple on prend hélas si tout
reprend h3 simplement
alors qu'est ce qu'on pourrait jouer
donc que jouer car les trois échecs ça
bloque la tour sur b3 et pascal alors un
an le roi noir pourrait venir mais on
pourrait faire encore un échec ça fait
beaucoup d'échecs et peut-être peut-être
alors admettons enfin ce cavalier trois
échecs
bref quatre câbles et des cinq échecs
droit au f5 et on pourrait essayer tour
est ce que c'est vraiment jouable pour
protéger le pion parce que sinon s'il
tente c'est terminé admettons qu'ils
étaient au troll on tour 3 que font les
noirs mais ils prennent cas il prend
hélas échec
en plus ce jour 1 4 est là simplement on
va jouer blessé deux on va prendre ça ça
va être bon ça non parce qu'on va perdre
b3 assez simple on perd des trois essais
deux rois la cavale et prendre 3 c3 et
on perd b3 masse on ne peut pas empêcher
la perte de l'e3 et donc que les noirs
vont illuminer le dernier pion et c'est
nul voila et voilà donc fawcett cac
valeo 5 échecs en même si ce câble et
j'ai quatre échecs on peut pas prendre
le pion aux enfers en plus ils auraient
pu tenter de plan de paix en colombie le
voir seul temps du vin est ici l'on
croit et vii
on garde le contrôle foule veut pas
rentrer là dedans et pas donner des
chances et qu'arsène tout simplement et
il joue car c'est ni six tours 6 toi
aussi ce jeu restera le roi sur la
sixième je peux jouer tourage 6 derrière
pour un entourage 7 qui va repousser le
roi effectivement et qui rendent plus
permettra de jouer le 6 mai jeu si je
paierai de pions c'est pas grave les
noirs sacrifie alors c'est ce qu'ils
font les tons proches 3 ça y est ça ça
tombe ça ça a pas l'air de tenir
longtemps et si on défend on active le
roi vrai c'est très dur voyez d'avancé
pas réussi car c'est malgré tout plus
cavalier cinq échecs
maintenant on repousse au point noir
faut garder contact avec le foot sinon
il est perdu on y par exemple 3,8 aux
ouailles fuite mais non on frias c'est
incroyable il fait cette fois l'étonnant
3g sept voiliers seuil est ce à dire que
là déjà il sait que il sait qu'il peut
s'en sortir même s'il donne le foot
c'est terrible donc là car ça nous prend
et sec
pourquoi parce que il va venir
réussissent attaqué le fou la tour
attaqué le kava les attaques et f5
or il ya aussi b3 qu'ils ont prise vous
voyez on a éliminé tous les pions et
ouais vous voyez que c'est pour ça qu'il
n'était pas trop inquiet malgré le
désavantage
l'avantagé était sans doute insuffisant
parce qu'il n'y avait pas cette pions
roi m6 maintenant alors les blancs
jouent ici c'est très physique qu'est ce
qu'on fait on peut aussi position c'est
ce qui va faire un protégé la tour
mais elle sait qui est en prise il
aurait pu jouer tour 8 aussi mais il je
choisis un autre coup je visite qu'avait
laissé six pas inintéressant ils
attaquent b4 enfin en attaque
attention il protège la tour surtout la
série noire de jouer ils prennent le
curé pts 5
ça c'est fait il laisse pas le temps
blanc de jouer le roi en défense du pion
il élimine ceux qui rendent dangereux le
pion h4 est potentiellement dangereux
aussi faudra qu'il s'en occupe et
surtout bb3 reste en prison voilà il n'y
a pas moyen pour les blancs des fans à
part de jouer cavalier des quatre mais
il ne fait pas grève
qu'est ce qui se serait passé sur calais
dès qu'on peut regarder quels et des
quatre échecs
voilà bon droit à l'erreur lors en noir
rouge ou airois f4 avec la la menace en
fait tour des trois attaques lecavalier
tu peux pas tout défendre et en plus
attention le plus rage va avancer donc
les blés blanche devront faire attention
à ça au défendre le cavalier tout en
empêchant le pion avancé tout en sachant
que si on bouge lecaillon père v3 et
c'est terminé
il vient que l'activité des noirs est
largement suffisante malgré la pièce de
moins ça suffit pas il faut ici on
regarde pas ce pion qui est qu'on peut
pas garder finalement on peut pas gagner
qu'à laisser 6,6 pour 3.5 on élimine un
des derniers pions cavalia 5 protège le
pur b3 c'est très important si on veut
espérer gagner mais maintenant est-ce
qu'on peut à la fois protéger le
cavalier tout hangar tout temps mais il
faut prendre b4 maintenant pour les
blancs pour progresser mais si on nord
de jouer on va voir tout de suite quand
même tour à cheval a tout simplement ce
pur h&o en plus aussi toujours une
menace
c'est ça qui est pénible si on fait
échec pour éloigner le roi noir façon
que laurent blanc puisse enlever qu'on a
est ta question mais le roi n'en va les
cueillir
tout ça en revenir en b3 ou voir même en
bessin qu'attaquer mission sans doute en
b3 pauvres en c3 pour garder un oeil sur
détroit on peut attaquer le carrier avec
la tour et on peut même sans doute d'un
certaine variante envisager tout
reprendre pions cavalli prend ra prend
et si laurent blanc est assez loin ce
qui est le cas pour l'instant litres est
quand même très loin
et bien ce pion va aller à dame et la
tour de bras
devant se sacrifier donc tout c'est tout
c'est elles suffisent à comprendre même
sans calculer que les mêmes sont
calculées que les que les peulhs et noir
en fait non on ne risque pas grand chose
dans cette ligne party tour bessette
sauf sauf soif évidemment sauf erreur
tactique parce que ni sur sa joue alors
tomber cette sait si bien joué bien sûr
on veut simplement prendre b4 avec cette
fois la tour qui protège le plus
l'attention parce que là si si ça tombe
le cavalier la tour est donc un pion de
+6 et archi gagnant là par contre
attention donc il faut pas que les noirs
traîne on voit la tour 1 on enlève le
bien sûr on attaque le défenseur tombé 5
on perd pas de temps en attaque le roi
tout en protégeant le cavalier tout un
temps tout en ayant un oeil sur sur b4
c'est là qu'il faut être précis droit f4
la preuve qu'il a très bien joué
magnifique c'est le seul coup je pense
mais ça suffit on peut pas avec les
blancs prendre le pion et oui pourquoi
qu'est ce qui se passe je vous laisse
deviner up
ici on prend 1,4 à les deux secondes
vous avez deux secondes voilà vous avez
trouvé bien entendu maths c'est quand
même terrible vers gaza
les maths en latéral comme ça parfois on
les voit pas donc attention attention
mais sur un piège classique voilà assez
c'est une défense en direct du pion et
ce pion est une contre menace suffisante
pour que les blancs et pas le temps de
ramener le roi pour essayer voilà de
profiter de à la fois de gagner b4 tout
en gardant b3 faut être précis mais ça
suffit
ceci dit en jouant avec quatre aussi on
se heurte bien entendu à tour prendre b4
échec donc le roi doit jouer et je vais
pouvoir
j'ai gagné le pion tout en ayant le pion
de plus mais regardez ça suffit toujours
pas puisque 3 g iii et voilà c'est
terminé
attention maintenant si vous prenez h4
vous perdez la partie puisque tout
reprendre cavaliers échec
le roi est obligé de partir et on prend
la tour on card pièces d'un coup donc
attention ici roigé 3 e menaces
attention d'aller à dame
et oui c'est le noir en fait qui seront
presque mieux ici regardez comme
lecavalier protège les trois qui est en
plus à la bande ici il complètement hors
jeu il peut pas bouger
sopo tesco b3 de laisser mes trois ans
pris il n'a pas le temps il y aura des
comme celle en garde hier le temps qu'il
arrive l'autre côté 1 il faut du temps
la différence avec le food tout à
l'heure donc là les blancs jouent quand
même joli coup qui est touché quatre
échecs pas mal bien sûr ben qu'est ce tu
fais si tu viens h3b je prends avec
échec
et là c'est pas la même là les bleus ont
gagné donc il faut surtout parler h3
dont policiers durant prise mais c'est
pas grave puisque le rappeler si on et
puisqu'on est parti on a le cavalier qui
est en prison donc les bleus auront le
temps de jouer roi f2 très joli coup et
si les blancs prennent en h4 avec le roi
tout reprend et si la position est nul
ici grâce à notre ami philidor finale
deux tours
et puis le roi est de toutes façons
d'aimer place et il va il va on va même
gagné le pion puisqu'il a on n'a pas le
temps de le roi blanc il trop loin et on
va avancer on pressent que je pense
qu'on vienne le pion même sans calculer
donc non ça va pas donc il faut faire
quelque chose mais si on défend le
cavalier le pion attention vallée adam
par exemple si on joue tour à 4 en 10
ans mais échanger lecavalier pions
contre roy et mais non parce que h 3 h 2
h 1
c'est fini il n'y a pas le temps
d'empêcher la dame puisque le roi noir
protège de toute tentative de venir
empêcher le tueur d'avancé et reste le
seul coup ici pour essayer de tenir
la position ces tours j'ai cinq ans n'e
vite et on échange mais c'est pareil h 3
h 2 h
ce pion permet aux noirs de garder
l'équilibré
ça se joue à peu de chose mais bon on
sentait que voilà que cela passait deux
pions malgré l'avantagé était trop trop
éloignés trop éclaté on l'avait dit et
voyez que le fourrage ou a rempli son
office et qu'il a même pu se sacrifier
pour aller manger les derniers pions
donc ici qu avait laissé quatre sur
scène mais c'est au noir / h 3 voilà
c'est là contre champ ce qui suffit il y
avait aussi ce petit pion attention je
file à dam le seul coup pour contrôler
la poussée ces messieurs entourage 4,3 g
3 mai sur paroi g2 puisque ce roi g2 ils
re sans doute un cas d échec et le câble
il revient en jeu il faut pas laisser le
temps de revenir donc faut pas lui
permettre de faire un échec avec gain de
temps
roy ici j'ai trois à six le cas les
bouges attention tout à 5 hir à imaginer
que le cavaly viennent en jeu par an aux
trois pour essayer de la de venir à
l'aide ici de la tour pour empêcher les
pions d'avancé
il ya le fameux ici attention là encore
retour à cinq échecs
le roi ne peut pas venir ici puisqu'elle
roi adverse il faut partir en perd la
tour et le pion h3 un fils adam c'est la
cata non moi j'ai trois ici simplement
tour chez quatre échecs et bien sûr le
fameux roi f2 il va y avoir une
répétition ici parce que faire sinon il
va perdre la partie là le pian h sauf si
la dame voit la super défense de karuïa
qui n'ont la vue belle partie de cartes
scène aussi on peut dire que là quand
même il ay là il est passé pas loin
il aurait fallu une faute de carre
yakine légère faute à un moment donné
qu'il aurait pu faire un peu n'importe
quand mais il a joué très précis jusqu'à
sacrifier comme il fallait s'en fou
comme on l'a vu
afin de manger les derniers pions blancs
ses pions qui était finalement trop
faible trop éclatée le coût des trois
tous très joli coup de karuïa qui on
active notre pièce au prix d'un pion
mais en même temps en éclatant les pions
adverse
voilà un bel défense stratégique de
kajaki une belle partie de belles
finales à étudier
en détail ici on a vu quelques grands
thèmes ici mais bien sûr ça mériterait
beaucoup de points mériteraient
approfondissement c'est très difficile
de tout calculer mais mes joueurs de
call qui ne peuvent pas tout calculé
tous les coups à chaque fois donc inclus
beaucoup mais pas tous c'est ça reste
complexe et on voit bien le style carsen
capable de trouver de belles parties
tendu d'attac dans des finales qui a
priori semble terne au départ mais non à
nantes qui recèle on le voit beaucoup de
venir et c'est comme ça que carsen
réussi à devenir champion du monde
pour cette grande capacité à dire mais
la partie ne démarre pas au premier coup
mais peut-être au 20e dans une finale
que qui te semble peut être égal mais
moi je pense qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
choses à dire un peu là capablanca
revoilà donc merci d'avoir suivi pour
cette troisième partie très belle très
belle défense de kayak in très beau jeu
de quartiers nos six superbes parties
nulles encore bon ils sont à égalité et
on a du beau jeu on a même du très beau
jeu très belle partie d'échecs
très beau match la prochaine car lykina
les blancs on va voir comment il va
cuisiner
notre ami norvégien est ce qui va lui
faire un saumon à la norvégienne on va
voir ça va être intéressant à suivre
merci de m'avoir suivi donc sur les
monnaies tv pour cette troisième partie
championnats du monde 2007 et je vous
donne donc rendez vous à la prochaine
au revoir